[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Raquel garidau bonjour merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation député
la France insoumise de la scène saint-en
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représenté par Stéphane
Vernet de West France bonjour Stéphane
bonjour Orian bonjourel garid bonjour
bonjour c'est Raquel garidau pardon on
va commencer en parlant de cette marche
contre l'antisémitisme qui a eu lieu
dimanche 182000 personnes qui étaient
réunies dans toute la France euh est-ce
que c'est une faute de la part de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de la direction de
la France insommise de ne pas y avoir
pris part c'était un très bon réflexe
d'organiser une manifestation citoyenne
pour que les Français aient un moment
commun pour marquer une réprobation
totale de l'antisémitisme je rappelle
quand même euh à tout seigneur tout
honneur que l'idée était partie de
Olivier fort quand même des rangs de
laanupesse c'est chez nous qui qui avait
qui était sorti ce réflexe et c'est pas
anodin c'est pas c'est pas un hasard en
fait que il y ait chez nous ces
anticorps là euh bon ensuite ça a été
repris par comme vous le savez par
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
voilà et Gérard Larcher euh qui
malheureusement n'ont pas créé les
conditions pour que à Paris il est tout
le monde et notamment la confusion
qu'ils ont euh maintenu à l'égard de
l'extrême droite a été très péjorative
cela dit mais c'est-à-dire c'est leur
responsabilité eux ils ont lancé un
appel à une marche civique ils n'ont
appelé aucun parti à manifester et ça
c'est une grande naïveté c'est une
grande naïveté de de dire ceci parce que
tous les citoyens euh ne sont pas euh à
la tête de d'organisation d'extrême
droite d'accord donc euh le citoyen
Zemour c'est ou le la citoyenne Marine
Le Pen et tout son état-major euh c'est
pas c'est pas des forces politiques je
veux dire anodine elle ce sont ce sont
des forces qui euh on ont pour fonction
dans la société française de faire
développer le regard xénophobe le regard
discriminant notamment à l'égard des
Français d'origine musulmanes et donc
ces lunettes là qui sont les lunettes du
racisme ce sont les mêmes que celles de
l'antisémitisme c'est c'est la raison
pour laquelle il y avait une gêne et
plus qu'une gêne même quelque chose qui
qui pour certains était vraiment
résolument impossible à à à à procéder à
une sorte de de de antiracite wasing
ouis mais pourquoi ne pas être allé
manifester a avec vos partenaires de
gauche alors alors cela dit cela dit euh
je je sais que la majorité je sais que
la l'écrasante majorité des personnes
qui ont manifesté dimanche partout en
France
l'été contre
l'antisémitisme ça va c'est évident ça
va de soi je j'ai pu le constater
moi-même à Strasbourg d'ailleurs vous
êtes manif onler voilà j'ai manifesté à
Strasbour mais du coup je repose ma
question est-ce que c'est une faute de
ne pas vous être joint à ce cortège avec
vos partenaires de je je constate que
nous l'avons fait nous avons été de
nombreux députés notamment en région à
le faire que ce soit mon collègue Léo
Valter à Digne mon collègue Rodrigo
Arenas en Avignon mon collègue Sébastien
Rome dans l'hérau et et et nombre nombre
d'entre nous ont eu ont eu ce réflexe
tout à fait sain de de manifester dans
ces dans dans dans ce cadrelà
euh je suis pas certaine que je suis pas
certaine que la les polémiques qui sont
né avant pendant et après la marche de
Paris finalement soit le cœur de ce qui
doit nous préoccuper et fondamentalement
je pense que nous ne devons pas placer
en concurrence la la bataille
antiraciste la bataille contre
l'antisémitisme et la bataille actuelle
en cours pour le cesser le feu et la
paix à Gaza et et j'ai l'impression que
c'est là qui se niche une erreur
politique c'est-à-dire de d'oser pard
est-ce que le premier à tout mélanger
n'est pas Jean-Luc Mélanchon non mais
c'est c'est c'est à ça donc que je fais
référence je je pense que c'est là que
se niche l'erreur on n pas notre travail
nous dans la société n'est pas de mettre
en
concurrence les les les réflexes
citoyens voilà les indignations les
colères que nous avons en tant que
citoyen aujourd'hui on peut parfaitement
manifester pour un Gaza et d'ailleurs
nous le ferons ce weekend puisque je
rappelle qu'il y a à nouveau une grande
mobilisation à Paris pour le cesser le
feu samedi et d'ailleurs ces
mobilisations portent des fruits par je
considère que la le le bouger dans la
dans la position du président de la
République nécessairement enfin je le
constate vient aussi de cette
mobilisation on va en parler mais
Jean-Luc Mélenchon fait une erreur en
mélangeant tout pour vous mais madame
Oran vous vous voulez absolument me
faire dire du mal de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
moi je ce que j'essaie de développer
mais je crois vous l'avez peut-être
compris non mais venir attendez je vais
vous dire quelque chose et j'aimerais
que tout le monde l'entende je suis pas
porte-parole de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça ça
on l'a bien compris on va y venir mais
non mais non mais c'est très important
c'est-à-dire que moi aussi j'essaie
d'incarner quelque chose de différent
donc quand vous voulez poser des
questions à Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous lui
poser et on tous ont grandit et
peut-être que vous aussi vous devez
grandir un petit peu c'est-à-dire de
arrêter de voir la vie autour des tweets
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon en tout cas Mo
mais sauf que vous appartenez encore à
son partir à quel garideau c'est lui qui
appartient aussi au mien enf dire oui
voilà mais vous êtes encore vous êes
encz les questions à lui et moi
posez-moi des questions sur ce que j'ai
essayé sur ce que j'ai fait sur ce que
j'ai fait moi di on va y venir mais
quand il y a eu quand il y a eu cette
marche à laquelle vous étiez on va en
parler quand il y a 182 quand il y a
182000 personnes dans la rue et que lui
à peine la marche terminée il qualifie
la marche d'échec en disant la droite et
l'extrême droite on Rabou gris est rendu
en Biget de l'antisémitisme je je vous
l'ai dit je pense que chercher querelle
au personnes qui ont manifesté N n'a pas
de sens parce que au fond on voulait
quoi que les gens n'aillent pas
manifester contre contre contre
l'antisémitisme ça n'a pas de sens ça
n'a pas de sens nous sommes les tenants
de ce fil historique qui nous
différencie de l'extrême droite donc on
ne peut pas apparaître même
par par confusion je veux dire par
connexité comme ceux qui veulent
affaiblir cette cette indignation
populaire cette indignation
citoyenne à l'égard du racisme et de
l'antisémitisme Stéphane ouais enfin
c'est quand même un peu ce qui s'est
passé dimanche midi avec Manuel Bompard
sur le plateau de de BFM TV quand manuel
bpard donc le coordinateur de la France
insoumise dit juste avant la manif que
ceux qui vont participer à cette pif
vont participer à une opération visant à
réhabiliter l'extrême droite ou à nier
le caractère antisémite du du
rassemblement national qu'est-ce qu'il
veut faire passer comme message est-ce
qu'il est pas en train justement de
chercher à dissuader les gens d'aller
défiler en tout cas ça n'a pas marché
bah tant mieux
ben que que que l'on que l'on que l'on
énonce sans naïveté l'opération de
marine lepen et d'Éric Zemour et de la
LDJ parce que je rappelle quand même
qu'il avait dans cette mobilisation et
puis on le dit peu mais il a eu des
échaufouré à la fin assez grave des des
agressions de la part d'un group tout
petit de tout petit groupe moi j' étais
ils étaient vraiment pas nombreux du
tout il y avait plus 100000 personnes
dans la rue quand même on est d'accord
on est d'accord sur les proportions
c'est c'est un c'est un fait ce que vous
dit là est en fait la grande masse et je
je l'ai dit la grande masse des gens qui
étaient là étaient serein Pacifique
digne fédéré mais c'est quand même un
fait également que Marine Le Pen c'est
c'est assez pavané avec son état-major
c'est un fait qu'il avait Éric Zemour
qui aujourd'hui est un raciste
multicondamné pour pour des propos
notamment à l'égard à l'égard à l'égard
de nos compatriotes arabes ou d'origine
musulmane et que et qu'une et et qu'un
groupuscule
agressif armé considéré comme terroriste
en Israël et et aux États-Unis la LDJ
était présente pour soutenir Marine Le
Pen tout ça est une réalité la réalité
est complexe et donc la dire dans sa
complexité fait partie aussi du travail
des députés que nous sommes mais je le
dis je le dis je je trouve qu'il y a
quand même quelque chose de très il a on
est à front renversé si vous voulez le
rôle des insoumis n'est pas de
reférainer l'aspiration des citoyens à
lutter ensemble contre on pouvait le
dire on pouvait le dénoncer on pouvait
dénoncer ses présences et ses
participations et venir manifester quand
même ce qu'on fait les socialistes qu'on
fait les écologiste écoutez moi j'ai
trouvé moi j'ai trouvé moi comme
d'autres députés euh que ce soit à
Strasbourg avec mes collègues Clémentine
otin François Ruffin Alexis corbierre
Emmanuel Fernandez et comme je le disais
tout à l'heure nombre d'autres collègues
et de militants qui ne sont pas des
députés aussi parce que des insoumis
dans les marches de dimanche partout en
France puisqu'il y a eu 70 marches les
insoumis y étaient d'accord bon donc oui
effectivement je pense que la direction
de la France insoumise de ce point de
vue est un peu en décalage avec ce que
les insoumis représentent et font à
l'échelle de de notre propre histoire et
et à l'échelle du pays comment vous avez
perçu ou vécu les propos du député David
guirot en Tunisie le même weekend ou où
en fait il justifie les horreurs
commises par le Hamas en accusant à
Israël de faire la même chose très mal
très mal parce que ce sont des erreurs
factuelles des erreurs historiques
et un et un discours qui est qui est
profondément inacceptable je crois que
bon la chose lui a été dite chose lui a
été
dite pas refuse de le sanctionner ça il
y a il y a
une il y a un problème à la Direction de
la France insoumise il y a besoin
d'avoir à à mon sens un sursaut là un
sursaut
éthique j'ai l'impression que leur
boussole je sais pas
c'est c'est c'est déboussolé voilà elle
elle ne marche plus donc il y a besoin
que les insoumis voilà se ressaisissent
fent du commun dans l'unité et je sais
que c'est pas simple parce que c'est
vrai n nos contradictions nos
oppositions sont
aujourd'hui publiques et ce n'est pas
simple à articuler mais il y a besoin de
de de ce sursaut vraiment j'appelle
j'appelle la direction de la France
insoumise à déjà faire le son propre
bilan il y a un an lorsque cette
direction s'est autoproclamé entre entre
guillemets elle a dit attendezil y en a
que pour un an on fera le point à la
prochaine assemblée représentative en
décembre là on y
vient objectivement leur bilan est
mauvais et et puis il y a des il y a une
sorte de voilà une sorte de gêne j'ai
moi j'ai une gêne donc en ce qui
concerne pardon une gêne à être encore
dans ce parti avec avec avec la dire
vous voulez absolument me mettre en
marge du parti quel gne ma gêne par
rapport à à la position qui a été prise
par la direction et notamment manuel
bonpard c'est pas que je ne la partage
plus c'est que elle c'était pas notre
position je dire ce n'était pas notre
position moi j'ai l'impression dans ce
cadre là d'être une insoumise on ne peut
plus banale et Canal historique voyez
j'ai pas du tout l'impression que c'est
moi qui bougé j'ai pas du tout
l'impression peut-être que je me trompe
mais mais j'ai l'impression d'être
d'être solide sur mes assises et mes
principes qui sont ceux qui constituent
mon
engagement dans dans cette organisation
et donc voilà je je je pense qu'il faut
faut s'amender il faut se regarder en
face et il faut aussi corriger faut
corriger mais on comprend plus la la la
stratégie ou le dessin de de de ce de ce
mouvement je sais pas si vous avez
entendu manuel valalls sur France Info
TV samedi qui accusait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui disait mais Jean-Luc
mélenchonit veut tout faire pour que
Marine Le Pen gagne 2027 de façon à
précipiter une espèce de chaos en France
dont il don il don la France insoumise
pourrait tirer parti est-ce que ça c'est
de la politique fiction ou estce qu'il y
a part de vrai dans ce dans ce manuel
Vals d'abord polémiquer avec Manuel Vals
je vois pas l'intérêt parce que pour moi
il représente vraiment pour
le cette espèce de calcul qui
consisterait à à pousser remblementtion
choisissez des références autres que
Manuel V manuel c'est la loi de
déchérance de nationalité donc c'est a
bien qui ont pasavé le chemin de
l'extrême droite c'est eux d'accord
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite a prospère
aussi sur l'échec de la socialdémocratie
et justement notre fonction historique à
nous était de s'assurer que ce que que
les erreurs grossières de la de la
socialdémocratie n'aboutissent pas à à
la disparition totale de du fil
historique de l'émancipation et du
progrès que nous représentons donc je ne
veux même pas débattre avec Manuel Vals
contre laanup qui au demant est contre
laanupes depuis depuis le premier jour
et contre l'unité des force populaire
démocratique écologique sociale pour la
victoire et roule pour l'adversaire il
roule pour Macron il roule pour
l'extrême droite donc moi je suis dans
une logique qui est de fédérer voilà de
prendre le pouvoir en 2027 de prendre le
pouvoir face au macronist d'empêcher
l'extrême droite de gouverner parce que
nous avons des choses à faire nous avons
une une une démocratie à mettre en place
nous devons passer à la 6e République
nous devons limiter le réchauffement
climatique nous devons reprendre toute
cet argent qui est concentré à caparé
entre les mains de quelquesuns au
détriment de la grande masse des
Français voilà ce que nous avons à faire
et c'est pour ça que je plaide pour
l'unité depuis le départ l'unité de la
nupè l'unité de la France insoumise
l'unité du peuple et ce que je regrette
vraiment c'est de voir comment cette
petite poignée de de collègues de
camarades qui aujourd'hui dirigent la
France insoumise au lieu de fédérer ne
font que de se rapetisser ne font que de
cLIV on a l'impression qu'à la fin s'il
se retrouvent à trois ils vont être
contents bon mais c'est pas ça faire de
la poli politique c'est pas ça paver un
chemin pour gagner c'est c'est
exactement l'inverse nous avons fait 22
% à l'élection présidentielle nous avons
fait 26 % au premier tour de la
Législative notre rôle historique c'est
de gagner donc faisons en sorte deux
voilà mais est-ce que les les premierers
à mettre à mal l'unité de la nupè ce
n'est pas eux et est-ce que la nupè
pourra tenir tant qu'il y a Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et la direction de la France
Insou il faudra que la nupess tienne on
n pas on n' pas d'autres choix on n' pas
d'autres chemin vers la victoire et je
rappelle quand même à chacun sauf
qu'ellelose aujourd'hui députés les
députés qui ont été élus sur sur le
label de l'anupes ont été élus sur un
programme je le disais ce programme de
de de rupture avec la social-démocratie
et aussi sur un une stratégie de
rassemblement ce sont les deux jambes de
la nups chaque député élu nups reste
nups il doit à son électorat fidélité à
ce programme et à cette stratégie de
rassemblement nous sommes 150 députés
donc c'est notre travail de continuer
euh au moins à l'Assemblée nationale qui
est le cœur du du on va dire du réacteur
nucléaire de laanupes à faire des choses
ensemble nous le faisons d'ailleurs dans
les différentes commissions le groupe de
travail que je copilote par exemple sur
le passage à la 6e république continue
son travail non seulement à l'Assemblée
avec des auditions parlementaires mais
également dans le pays puisque nous
faisons maintenant des auditions
populaires je serai à Toulouse euh en
décembre par exemple
mais mais aujourd'hui Raquel garido elle
fonctionne plus cette nupes il a il y a
plus de réunion de l'intergroupe mais il
y a plus il y a plus de réunion de
l'intergroupe il y a un moratoire euh
des socialistes il y a Fabien Roussel
qui dit qu'il veut partir de la nupes
bon factuellement aujourd'hui elle ne
tient plus ce qu'on comprend pas c'est
pourquoi vous et parce que vous n'êtes
pas toute seule sur cette ligne à la
France insoumise pourquoi vous ne
reconstruisez pas quelque chose avec les
socialistes avec les écologistes avec
les communistes en vous séparant de la
direction de la France insoumise mais
encore une fois vous donner l'impression
de vouloir absolument cette session donc
de ce point de vue vous êtes un peuir
inversé de ceux qui chez moi poussent
les gens vers l'extérieur donc donc je
le dis Non Non mais pourquoi elle est
pas là actuellement elle est pas là
aujourd'hui c moi je considère que les
étatmajors sont en échec tous les
état-majors EUV parce qu'ils ont
absolument voulu faire leur liste à
part
européennes Rousell parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il y a rien d'autre qui
l'intéresse que ce peti écurie
présidentielle tout le monde est en
échec et alors nous les députés nous ne
sommes pas élus par nos directions nous
ne sommes pas nous sommes élus par des
citoyens les nos électeurs nous ont
donné un mandat nous devons être fidèles
c'est une forme d'éthique de notre
propre pouvoir de de de de politique
donc euh on peut pas se défausser moi je
me défausse pas je ne dis pas ah bah vu
que Roussell et Mélenchon sont fâchés ah
bah du coup ah bah j'arrête tout ah
j'arrête tout et j'attends comme ça que
Messieurs ser raboche mais enfin on
n'est pas des enfants je ne suis pas un
enfant aucun d'entre nous n'est n'est là
pour faire de pour faire de de la
décoration autour de gens qui ont envie
de de de s'entre voilà de
s'entredredéchirer nous sommes
responsable et coresponsable de notre
propre histoire politique mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes encore
réconciliable parce que c'est ça la
question mais il le faudra madame il le
faudra sinon on gagnera jamais la thèse
des deux gauches irréconciliables c'est
la thèse de Manuel Vals c'est celle qui
donne les clés du camion à l'extrême
droite et au macronistes donc je moi je
suis quelqu'un de très franc quand je
suis en désaccord je je le dis mais je
pense que la noblesse de la politique
c'est de se mettre d'accord avec des
gens avec qui on est parfois en
désaccord et c'était ça qui était beau
dans la nuupes et je crois que c'est
pour ça que les gens nous savent gré de
l'avoir réalisé en juin 2022 et ils nous
serons gré à celles et ceux qui
construiront ce même chemin pour la
victoire en 2027 mais
est-ce vous avez été sanctionné de 4
mois pendant lesqueles vous ne pouvez
plus prendre la parole le 7 novembre
vous disiez humilié en colère avoir
honte aujourd'hui vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit j'ai le cœur brisé mais le
cœur vaillant évidemment je suis en
colère par rapport à cette procédure qui
est d'abord une procédure opaque
profondément opaque les éléments de la
procédure les éléments du dossier n'ont
été donné à personne ni au groupes
parlementaires ni à mes électeurs parce
que je rappelle quand même que les
citoyens de ma circonscription ont mené
une bagarre homérique contre
Jean-Christophe Lagarde ils ont dégagé
un élu qui était là depuis 20 ans de la
droite affairiste et donc si je suis là
c'est pour porter euh les les voix des
habitants de bumini de Drancy du Bourget
et alors un groupe de 20 personnes
s'arroge le droit de dire à ses électeur
là ah ben vous n'aurez pas une députée à
100 % vous aurez une députée qu'à 50 %.
bon et et sans donner le début de
commencement d'un élément factuel qui
leur permet à eux de juger pas même à
vous bah moi on m'a donné des éléments
bien sûr et vous allez les rendre publ
oui absolument mais bien sûr et je le
donne à quiconque me le demande mais
bien sûr euh la procédure par définition
toute procédure doit être transparente
l'opacité ne produit qu'arbitraire et
injustice et ce qui me fascine c'est à
quel point mes camarades du bureau du
groupe parlementaire ne le voi pas ils
passent leur journée à dénoncer
l'opacité du fonctionnement de de de
yelbron Pivet comment yelbron Pivet a
utilisé le bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale pour essayer de rendre
irrecevable la loi sur les retraites qui
avaient été pourtant déclaré recevable
antérieurement il il tous les jours nous
dénonçons les passages en force 493
l'utilisation du 471 pour faire passer
la loi retraite tous les jours nous
dénonçons ces opacités ces arbitraires
dans les procédure et comment ne pas
voir que si nous le nous faisons la même
chose chez nous nous perdons toute
crédibilité à dénoncer ces défauts
démocratique dans la 5e République donc
il faut être cohérent moi je souhaite
que que nous soyons cohérents si j'ai
fauté j'ai aucun problème je si j'ai
menti si j'ai violé une décision
collective je suis prête à me à me à me
soumettre à toute à tout toutes les
sanctions mais vousit face ben bien sûr
que non je me suisfend point manuel
bpard il dit que vous n'avez pas été
sanctionné pour avoir eu des positions
divergentes envers Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pour avoir critiqué Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais parce que vous n'avez pas respecté
des décisions collectives ouis je m'en
souviendrai alors à ce moment-là pour
dans la suite quand je dirai des choses
en désaccord avec Mélenchon alors c'est
permis alors c'est ce qu'il dit il dit
que c'est pas pour ça que vous avez été
sanctionné la vérité mais bon toute
façon je vais je vais tout je vais tout
donner hein que les chos qu'estce alors
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans dans
cette procédure et ben des des des
désaccords politiques c'est on on me
reproche des expressions publiques je
l'ai dit par exemple l'expression
publique du 22 octobre sur sur le bilan
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon depuis un an des
expression mais même on m'a même
reproché des expressions de février 2023
où je considère que des collègues
devraient démissionner de leur mandat de
conseiller régional parce que nous avons
une charte qui interdit le cumule des
mandats chez nous bon c'est tout à
l'avenant et on me monte une sorte de
dossier comme quoi j'aurais maltraité
des collaborateurs et ça je trouve ça
immonde c'està dire ça relève de de ce
que ferait un employeur lorsqu'il veut
monter un dossier pour un licenciement
abusif et qu'on qu'on entraîne des
collaborateurs là-dedans me semble
vraiment là pour le coup une un abus qui
est inacceptable mais mais moi je suis
pour la transparence voilà de toute
façon on ne se déf vous allez les rendre
publi quand comment bah déjà j'en ai
donné quelques éléments mais les membres
du groupe parlementaire moi j'ai demandé
au groupe parlementaire de lever ma
sanction je suis pas la seule d'ailleurs
les le premier adjoint de ma
circonscription à Bob le premier adjoint
de bobini qui n'est pas insoumis dit
mais nous c'est nous l'avons envoyé
là-bas donc au moins donnez-nous les
éléments donc ils doivent se saisir les
éléments et puis dans les régions aussi
les militants me l'ont demandé parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça débat partout à la
France insoumise et c'est ça peut-être
qui est finalement le le bien pour le
mal c'est que dans la France insoumise
partout les militants débattent de notre
fonctionnement de de de voilà de cette
sorte de rabougrissement de la direction
et ça c'est une bonne chose parce que
l'avenir de notre mouvement tient aussi
à la façon dont les insoumises et les
insoumis contrôlent leur organisation
contrôl leur chef obtiennent d'avoir un
protagonisme plus important politique au
sein de leur mouvement et donc je je
voilà je les je les remercie d'abord
pour leur soutien car j'ai reçu
énormément de soutien d'affection on va
dire
d'affection et mais maintenant il faut
voilà il faut agir faut avir
il faut qu'on cherche à à à faire à
solidifier l'unité de notre mouvement
qui est qui est en péril mais ca passe
cela passe par le le le rétablissement
d'un certain nombre de principes
importants une dernière question
Stéphane une dernière question sur le
sur l'actualité parlementaire le vote
solennel de la loi immigration aura lieu
aujourd'hui cet après-midi au Sénat donc
le la majorité
sénatoriale les républicains les
centristes ont beaucoup beaucoup durci
le texte comment est-ce que l'assemblée
peut le le reprendre et sur quoi vous
vous battrez vous à l'Assemblée sur ce
texte en décembre la la conversation
autour des
immigrés déjà quand même j'espère que
nous n'avons pas la
naïveté cette conversation est faite
pour qu'on ne parle pas d'autre chose
quand est-ce que Darmanin a eu l'idée de
commencer à mettre ce projet de loi
pendant le mouvement des retraites
pendant depuis le mouvement des
retraites cette loi était une sorte
d'arlaisienne qu'elle allait venir que
vous alliez voir que c'était programmé
tel jour et puis finalement non et
finalement oui c'était une façon de de
toujours maintenir vie vivant dans le
pays dans le dans le débat médiatique la
question de du problème des immigrés du
problème des immigrés alors moi je le
dis et en plus je le dis pas seulement
en tant que député insoumise il se
trouve que moi-même je suis immigré moi
je suis arrivée dans un avion à l'âge de
14 ans je suis devenue française à 25
ans voilà ce que je souhaite c'est quand
on allume le poste on nous fiche la paix
qu'on arrête qu'on arrête de de se
servir des immigrés pour résoudre les
problèmes de tout le monde voilà
aujourd'hui si les Français sont dans la
misère s'ils sont dans la galère si
l'inflation est galopante si on doit
choisir entre payer les chaussures des
enfants la cantine ou ou des vacances
c'est pas de la faute des immigrés donc
dararmanin ça suffit maintenant
c'estàdire on ne peut pas un jour dire
que nous allons lutter tous ensemble
contre les discriminations contre
l'antisémitisme et ensuite le lendemain
le lendemain dire ah mais attendez on a
trouvé un autre Bou émissaire c'est les
immigrés voilà donc ça suffit cette loi
sur les immigrés qui vient là elle ne
résout aucun problème de
sécurité le le le l'assassinat du
professeur Dominique Bernard parce que
Darmanin a quand même eu la
dégueulasserie de considérer que cette
loi allait résoudre ce type de
d'assassinat c'est faux c'est faux rien
dans cette loi ne rendra la vie
meilleure pour qui que ce soit merci
Raquel garito merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité Stéphane la Une de est
France ce sont les vill vertes l'Ouest
est champion des villes les plus vertes
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci à
tous les deux on passe au club des
territoires